so let's work an example together um
let's say we want to find what was the
example
in my head i think i wanted to do the
fifth roots
of and i'm going to give you an
arbitrary complex number somewhere else
not nice and neat like unity uh let's go
with
i'm gonna be i'm 90 sure this is what it
is i'll look it up in a second
uh this is a complex number somewhere
else
yes this is the one i want um i want to
find the fifth roots of
this number so i want you to because i'm
going to need to make some space but
i'll give you a minute to write this
down if you're still catching up
i want you to drop this down and think
about how we're going to form an
equation
with our fifth roots in it if this is
our particular
complex number i'll give you a clue all
of this working
except for the first line is not in
rectangular form
so the first thing you're going to have
to do is get things in an appropriate
shape to start doing this working okay
i'll give you a minutes
minute or two head start um and then i'm
gonna clear this off
and then we will have it go together
okay off you go
okay i can see some people have made a
good start for those of you who are like
still 100 confident let me give you a
bit of a nudge okay
so we're looking at the fifth roots of
negative root three
plus i which is given to you as it often
will be in rectangular form
but rectangular form kind of sucks for
finding nth roots so the first thing i'm
going to do
is work out what the modulus is what the
argument is and then i can go into
exponential form so real quick like
you'll get to the point you actually saw
me doing this
live when i was trying to remember if i
got this question this particular number
right um you'll get to the point where
you're like oh i can visualize
especially because these same numbers to
give you exact values will come up
over and over again because we don't
want to make it a pain for you
you'll start to think oh i know where
this number is so i can quickly verify
what my modulus or my argument should be
but until you get there
do yourself a favor draw yourself a tiny
little argon diagram
and think about where this is going to
be negative root 3 that takes you to the
left
of the of the complex plane because it's
negative root three over here plus i
takes you up
further um into the imaginary axis but
this is one and this is one point three
so here
is where i would place uh what did i
call it i'm calling it w
okay so if that's where w is if you have
a think about this triangle you create
in
here this is our one two root three
triangle
right one two oops wrong way around
one two and then root three on the
bottom
right so you're going to get pi on six
pi on three and pi on two
in this triangle you're just going to
know which one is which right um this
angle here is the one that's most
relevant to me what is the sign you can
even see it on my messy diagram which
angle is that
that's pi on 6. it's the smallest angle
right you can even see that just because
my scale is roughly close enough if that
angle is pi on 6
then the argument that i'm after
is the supplement of that it's 5 pi on
6. so i'm going to drop that down here
and i kind of sneakily already mentioned
this without writing it the hypotenuse
is the modulus that i'm after so that's
going to be
2. okay so therefore i can say
w equals 2 e to the i
5 pi on 6. and so now i'm kind of ready
to work out what my nth roots will be
i'm after the 5th roots right so i'm
going to say i don't just want this
i want like the 5 sorry the 4 after this
right
so what i'm going to do to sort of
minimize the amount of working that i'm
going to put down
i'm going to find the first solution
what i called before z1
and then i'm going to use my my sort of
the fact that i know they're going to be
spaced around
a circle with a particular circumference
and just use that to find the rest of
the solutions
okay so i'm going to say z1
will be this thing raised to the power
of
a fifth do you agree with that i'm
looking for fifth roots okay
so when you raise two to the power of a
fifth how would you write that this is
just a real number
this is it's the fifth root of two
right is that okay which is not like i
mean i've chosen numbers here for you so
the numbers are small
you might have gotten like say 32 on a
question who's trying to make things
easy for you because that's the fifth
power of two
but here i'm just going to write the
fifth root of two then i come to the
the argument part right so i'm going to
take this
and i'm going to divide by five oh
that's convenient so i'm going to write
i to the pi on
6 up here there's my first solution
because i've
divided this by 5. okay so there's my
first
solution i need to put some kind of
connective tissue here to explain
how i'm going to get from z1 to the
other roots z2 3
4 and 5. okay so i'm going to say
fifth roots i need to include that
are on i'm going to say a circle of
circumference
fifth root of two um you can say that
phrase a circle of circumference
fit through two or you can say thereon
the absolute value of z
equals the fifth root of two that's
another way of saying this is the circle
that has that circumference right and
they are equally spaced
what would be the spacing in this case
you can have a look i've already rubbed
it off but you can have a look at
how generalized working before we would
say they're 2 pi
on 5 in this case 2 pi on n
where n is equal to 5. so i'm going to
write 2 pi on
5 around the circumference
okay so this piece of connected tissue
it's really important you don't want to
just go to
like the next workings like where did
this come from okay as i work out z2 3 4
and 5
i'm explaining how i'm going to change
this and also i'm going to keep it the
same
so when i write z 2 for instance
because i know i'm on this same circle
what happens to this modulus for the
next solution
yeah it's the same modulus that's nice
okay but then you want to have to think
about the next
solution it's going to be um a to the i
my angle is going to change my argument
will change right
you're still going to start here but pi
on 6
you're going to add on what my spacing
is which in this case is
two pi on five okay now at this point
um i'm very happy for you to just reach
for your calculator uh
pi on six plus two pi on five is not the
main thing we want you to focus on in
this question
so if you want to reach for your
calculator don't worry about the pies
obviously
put in a sixth plus two-fifths what do
you get
17 30 is what i remember getting when i
was working this out
earlier 17 pi on 30 you should verify
that you're like oh yeah denominator
looks good
that's fine i've got my next one z
three i'm just going to go another two
pi on five right
so it'll be fifth root of two out the
front e to the i
same starter but i'm gonna go further
right
and calculators should hand you another
answer from memory it's
29 pi
okay now at this point i just want us to
pause um
you're maybe settling in what i say 29
maybe settling into autopilot
this is great like it's so um it's so
well set up for us the theory of it that
you just keep going you can go six pound
five and then eight pound five and then
you'll be done
but just briefly what i'd like us to do
even though it's not required
um is can we just quickly draw where
these are on an argon diagram because
this will be helpful for us
in a second if we draw we're eventually
going to get all five
of the fifth roots if we draw this on
you'll notice
uh there's some geometry you can take
advantage of here
okay so i'm going to draw my
imaginary and real axis
[Applause]
hold on to this one now my first
solution um or sorry rather all my
solutions i know are going to lie on the
circumference
of this particular circle here so just
to make things easier for myself
i'm going to put that circle onto here
so all my solutions can live there okay
so i'm going to go ahead and in fact i'm
going to use this color
i'm going to go around here's my here's
my circle
okay and it's
circumference or its radius rather will
be the 5th root of 2. so all my
solutions will sit somewhere on this
circle
okay and then from here i just need to
know the appropriate angles i've already
got three of my solutions so they
shouldn't be too hard to plot
i'm going to place pi on 6 about there
so this is
z1 this one here z2
17 pi on 30. now i just want to roughly
get a sense of where that is
um it's a little bit close to 15 pound
30 right just a bit further
than 15 pound 30. now the reason why i
think 15 pi and 30 like where'd that
number come from is
what does 15 30 simplify to pi on two
and i know exactly where that is here's
pi on two so
if this is fifteen pi and thirty
seventeen pi on thirty is just
a little bit further anti-clockwise do
you agree with that so i'm gonna place
that
roughly here there's my z2 and then my
um my third solution 29 pound 30 this is
very close to
30 pi and 30. where is 30 pound 30 on my
iron diagram
it's at pi isn't it right 30 30 is pi so
i'm just
short of that there's ish 29 pi on 30.
so there's my z3
so the way we've gotten our solution so
far is we got our first one
by using exponential form and then we
got our others
just by adding two pi
on five every time does that make sense
and so we've arrived at our third
solution so far now you can already see
like we're going to get this um a
regular penta a regular yeah a regular
pentagon
um i was gonna say regular polygon of
five size and realize i have a name for
those okay i'm gonna get my regular
pentagon shortly you can see i'm missing
solutions down the bottom here
but at this point i recognize there's a
better way to do this than to keep going
anti-clockwise if i kept going
anti-clockwise i'd still get a z4 and a
z5 it's fine okay
but your angle is going to be past
pi right so it's going to be a
non-principle argument that's okay you
can change it into a principal argument
but
why not just go for a nor sorry go for a
principal argument
in the first place rather than continue
going around
anti-clockwise what if i were to go
around
clockwise i'll still get these same
solutions it's just i can
skip one step of converting to a
principal argument okay
so i'm anticipating just looking at my
diagram right i'm anticipating a
solution around here
and a solution around here this will be
my z4
and my z5 the difference will be instead
of
adding 2 pi on 5 to go clockwise i
should
subtract okay
so i'll give you a nudge right my z4
and my z5 i'm still going to start from
my first solution
which in this case was fifth root of two
e to the i
pi on six fifth root of two e to the i
pi on six but i'll subtract two pi and
five to get this one
and then i'll subtract four pi and five
to get the very last one so that gives
me this
can you go ahead and uh work out what
those are and then we'll um put them on
the board
together all right so
we're uh we're pretty much there right
let me uh let me tie this up in a neat
bow
in two ways for starters here's one i
prepared earlier so this is obviously a
lot neater than the one um i did kind of
in a hurry here
but you could already know you're gonna
get roughly the right thing because
you can see my regular pentagon forming
there
and you can also see how i got the first
solution went to
two more and then went to the last two
going in different directions okay
now i should point out i sort of glossed
over something real quick here and
um lessons for why you should not skip
lines of working
uh this is you can see like we've got
you know in our first question
the focus is on complex numbers but we
had to use our trig identities and here
we're still focusing on complex numbers
the complex plane but i sort of snuck in
um index laws into here without really
going into detail of
why so let me just put in one
intervening line to hopefully make clear
even though it doesn't look obvious
right we're doing one thing to
everything here right so let me write
from
w right if i write w to the power of
a fifth and maybe um for those of you
who've already popped this working down
just like sneak it in on the side just
like i am so you can
really clearly get where this first
solution is coming from i'm just going
to write
everything in here and i'm going to
raise that to the power of fifth okay so
i did a lot of this index law stuff that
i'm about to write here
kind of in the background because we get
familiar with them right but for those
of you who are like kind of
i'm not quite there you've got two
numbers here a product
being raised to a power which is the
same as taking
each part of the product each factor and
raising them to that same power
independently so i could say that's 2 to
the power of a 5th
and then take a breath e to the i
5 pi on 6 to the power of a 5th so
there's my two
separate factors both being raised to
the same power
but then because i've got two somewhat
different looking things here i can
write them
somewhat differently right so this guy
here by our definition of what
fractional indices means
is the fifth root of two so that's where
i got it from
but here i can actually just use the
fact that in another color here
i've got these powers multiplying by
each other right
so the 5.6 multiplied by a fifth that's
what cancels
my fives and leaves me with that pi on
six over there so that's what
lands me on this spot um it is worth
putting like if you're
a person who's like i can see this is
something where my brain had to take
that extra step because i'm less
familiar with this then
then write the extra steps it's totally
fine um and we'll sort of give you a
spot where if
something goes wrong down the bottom
like you try and plop these you're like
that doesn't look like a regular
pentagon or they're all like
grouped up in one spot because you've
got the wrong angles this is the spot
you can go back and look at
to find your own error and that's
obviously super important okay